حسنًا
[موسيقى]
تقول CC الأجنبية إنك بحاجة إلى التصرف مع صندوق النقد الدولي ،
والبنك الدولي يقول جميعًا إنك بحاجة إلى التصرف ومع ذلك فإن
الحكومة لا تفعل شيئًا ما
تفعله تصدر تراخيص وقود أحفوري جديدة
تقول إننا بحاجة إلى استنزاف كل شيء أخيرًا  قطرة
نفط من بحر الشمال
تتعارض مع كل شيء تخبره به كل
هذه
الهيئات المحترمة دوليًا
[موسيقى
] أجنبية ، الرسائل واضحة ،
يخبرنا بها العلماء هذا الأسبوع الماضي فقط في
الأخبار التي قالت الأمم المتحدة إننا نديرها  من
الزمن يموت الناس في جميع أنحاء
العالم وسرعان ما سيأتي دورنا ، لذا حتى لو
كنا هنا في لندن لا نهتم بأي
شيء ببقية العالم ، يجب أن
نهتم بأنفسنا ، فأنا أهتم
ببقية العالم أعتقد أن الجميع  آخر
يهتم ببقية العالم
أجنبي
[موسيقى]